THE ROLL.
PORTANTINO I'M HERE PORTANTINO
HERE PLEASE.
BATES HERE BADFORD.
BRADFORD HERE HILL JONES WE CAL
SKI.
BECAUSE HE HERE.
ALL RIGHT OUR FIRST ORDER OF
BUSINESS IS TO ADOPT THE
COMMITTEE RULES SO I HEAR MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE BATES BATES AYE
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL.
JONES WE CASKEY HIGH WE CASKEY I
AN ON CALL.
ANYONE ELSE IS GONNA COME.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL MOVE ON TO OUR
A ONE ITEM OF BUSINESS AB ONE
FORTY NINE BY MISTER COOPER.
MR COOPER'S HERE SO PLEASE
PRESENT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL.
ONE FORTY NINE WILL OUT PATIENTS
TO RESUME FIT FILE FILLING
PRESCRIPTIONS FOR CRITICALLY
NEEDED MEDICATION.
BUT A LEADING THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF NEW REQUIREMENTS OF SECURITY
PRESCRIPTION FORMS.
WAS DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION WILL
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
TIME TO ASSURE THE SERIAL
NUMBERS ON SECURITY PRESCRIPTION
FORMS ARE VALID.
WILL ALSO ALLOW PRESCRIBERS TEND
TO COMPLY WITH REQUIREMENTS TO
UTILIZE THESE NEW SECURITY
PRESCRIPTION FORMS WHEN WRITING
PRESCRIPTIONS FOR CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES.
COST TO IMPLEMENT A BILL OR
MINOR.
OUR STATE VS FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
COULD YOU HAVE SPEAKERS AND
FAMOUS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
ROBINSON WE SHUDDER AND WE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION --
WERE THE SPONSORS OF AB ONE
FORTY NINE AND WE BELIEVE THE
BILL RIGHT DOJ SOME ADDITIONAL
TIME TO ROLL OUT THE NEW
MATERIALS --
REQUIRED FOR FILLING
PRESCRIPTIONS WERE.
CONSUMERS TO GET TO THE AIRPORT
MEDICATIONS.
AS MISTER COOPER NOTED WE
APPRECIATE STAFF ANALYSIS OF THE
BILL -- AND
THAT THESE COSTS OR MINOR AN
OBSERVABLE AND WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
ARE THERE OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS TO MADDEN
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
CARDIOLOGY IN THE CALIFORNIA
OCCUPATIONAL MEDICINE PHYSICIANS
ALL IN SUPPORT.
JENNIFER SAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
AND THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
TRAINED DRUG STORES IN SUPPORT.
MISSY JOHNSON WITH ME AS THE
MERC SUMMER HERE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
NON COOPER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FARMS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
ZACHARY CORAL CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION WE ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
MATT ROBINSON KAISER PERMANENTE
A IN SUPPORT.
JENNIFER SUMMERS OF THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
MARIA SPUR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
SURE ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEN OPPOSITION FINANCE HOW ARE
YOU HI GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ACTUALLY ON A
TEAR WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE --
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE --
ESTIMATES THE COST TO ADMINISTER
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL AT
FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY ONE
POINT ONE MILLION IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THOUSAND AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON GOING.
OF FINANCE WOULD NOTE HOWEVER
THAT THE AFOREMENTIONED FISCAL
IMPACT MAIN CORPORATE COSTS THAT
ARE ATTRIBUTABLE TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION.
OF AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND THIS THIS
POTENTIAL OVERLAPPING COSTS WILL
BE EVALUATED TO THE ANNUAL
BUDGET PROCESS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. TO MY COLLEAGUES
SEVENTY QUESTIONS.
BRADFORD I'M SECURE SINCE
EXAMPLE SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
YOU'RE FACING RIGHT NOW WITH
IMPLEMENTATION.
REFER A SPEAKER --
I'D IT'S I THINK THE UNCERTAINTY
THAT IT PROVIDES FOR INDIVIDUALS
THAT HAVE THE PRESCRIPTIONS --
IN HAND THAT WERE ISSUED LATE IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT.
THE NEW SYSTEM WAS WAS TO BE
ROLLED OUT FOR THIS PRESCRIPTION
TO TAKE EFFECT ON JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY NINETEEN THERE HAVE BEEN
SOME ISSUES WITHOUT ROLL OUT AND
SO WE DO HAVE FOLKS HAVE BEEN
DENIED.
PRESCRIPTIONS THERE ARE --
AS WE UNDERSTAND SOME SOME
RECALLS AND PUT IN PLACE BY --
THE DEPARTMENT JUSTICE AND
OTHERS TO ESSENTIALLY LACKS THE
ENFORCEMENT.
ON THOSE PRESCRIPTIONS ARE BEING
FILLED SHOULD THEY BE FILLED --
BUT STILL WE THINK THIS SAYS A
LOT MORE CLARITY --
TO THE CONSUMERS ABILITY TO GO
IN AND GET THOSE PRESCRIPTIONS
FILLED UNDER KIND OF THE OLD
SYSTEM.
WHILE GETTING DOJ A LITTLE BIT
MORE OF A SOME WIGGLE ROOM TO TO
BRING ON THE NEW.
MANDATORY PADS THAT HAVE TO HAVE
TO REALIZE NUMBERS AND THE TIE
BACK TO CURES DATABASE.
THE DOJ HERE [inaudible]
NO.
JUST IN CASE YOU WANT TO TEST
THEM ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
IS BANKS ANYTHING.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL I
WOULD DOUBT THAT THERE WERE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
CROSSED YESTERDAY IN THE NOW
CSUS RECOMMENDED OR REFLECTS --
THE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS I THINK
THAT WAS IMPORTANT SO THANK YOU
FOR DOING THAT THANK YOU --
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A
UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCE --
WHICH IS WHY WE'RE HERE --
AND WE HOPE THAT THE
IMPLEMENTATION HAPPENS IN MOOSE
AS SWIFTLY AS POSSIBLE.
AND WITH THAT WILL TAKE ABOUT.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES.
WE CASKEY.
BECAUSE HE I SO WE WILL.
KEEP THE BILL ON CALM MISTER.
HILL DO WANT TO ADD ON TO THE
ADOPTION OF THE COMMITTEE RULES.
WE WILL OPEN YOUR BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU.
AN ON CALL.
SO PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE ON OUR
RULES.
WELL.
HELL I THEY SORELY MISSING
MISTER JONES RAN.
SO WE WILL GIVE MISTER JONES A
COUPLE MINUTES TO GET HERE.
I WILL WAIT
AND OPEN THE ROLE IN
ADOPTING OF OUR RULES PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
JONES I JONES I NAY RULE SEVEN
ADOPTED AND THEN WE HAVE ONE
ORDER BUSINESS AND WE CAN OPEN
THE ROLE --
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FORTY NINE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
JONES.
HI.
JONES I BILL IS OUT AND EVERYONE
HAS VOTED AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE HAVE EASY [inaudible]
SEE THAT [inaudible]
REMEMBER THAT